all right guys we've had a lot of wind
overnight we know what that feels like
what it looks like and it puts dust in
the air and we've had a lot of that
we'll be looking for the dust to settle
down and things to clear out a little
bit
eventually we'll get back to some good
air quality but this morning it's kind
of moderate for that extra dust in the
air so if you're very sensitive to that
you might want to just stay indoors as
much as you can we have a lot of 70s
around the valley right now checking
temperatures 62 at red rock and we've
got 47 up on the mountain at kyle canyon
outside the valley it is cold up in ely
this morning look at that 28 degrees 49
in caliani 64 at indian springs 71 in
mesquite low 70's for boulder city
searchlight 68 windy in laughlin with
those north winds at 82 and 70 in prompt
this morning we'll be looking for the
winds to settle down through the
afternoon but we'll stay very very dry
few showers more thunderstorms over the
northern plains hot hazy humid after big
storms around the chicago area now
they're dealing with
so much oppressive heat and humidity
temperatures near 100 degrees today with
excessive heat warnings all those areas
of orange
kind of peachy orange those are heat
advisories so millions of people under
heat alerts today in the eastern half of
the u.s so the wind advisory is to the
south i mean sorry the cold front to the
south of us staying windy through the
morning and then we'll have lighter
winds in the afternoon now the fires are
still so dry and so much gusty wind
northern arizona this is flagstaff just
about six miles north of flagstaff 5 000
acres have burned this is the pipeline
fire there are a couple of smaller fires
too near this area and the winds
continue to blow this fire towards those
other two small ones so they could be
combined zero containment right now for
those fires so it is terrible it's just
so dry and they we all need rain in the
southwest today we're looking at
temperatures below normal for our
primary voting day tuesday also flag day
today mid 90s today we're popping right
back to triple digits and a hot thursday
at 108 more wind though before the
weekend and that will cool us back to
the 90s nice for father's day at 94
degrees on sunday